Clarence Gilyard Jr. appeared in some
of the biggest action movies of the 80s,
only to walk away from acting to become a beloved
professor. In the wake of his tragic passing,
let's take a look back at his
remarkable life and career.
"You know what, I don't even go by "junior"
anymore. I'm 63 years old, good heavens."
Die Hard actor, author, and university professor
Clarence Gilyard passed away at the age of 66 due
to an unspecified illness on November 28, 2022.
Born into a military family on December 24,
1955, Gilyard, the son of U.S. Air
Force Officer Clarence Gilyard Sr.,
initially attended the United States Air Force
Academy himself for a year before landing on his
true passion. He found success through roles in
not only Die Hard but also Top Gun and Walker,
Texas Ranger, but Gilyard semi-retired from
acting in 2005 to teach at the University
of Nevada Las Vegas' College of Fine Arts.
UNLV's Dean Nancy Uscher said in a statement:
Gilyard had 37 acting credits and managed to
win two awards. His most famous roles included
the over-the-top computer hacker Theo in
Die Hard, Lieutenant Junior Grade Marcus
"Sundown" Williams in Top Gun, and private
investigator Conrad McMasters on Matlock.
"I was also Santa Claus's elf at a Sears."
In an interview with getTV, Gilyard credited
Matlock star Andy Griffith as one of his mentors,
someone who taught him how to be funny
on-screen. GIlyard told the outlet:
After Matlock, Gilyard landed
one of his most well-known roles,
playing Ranger James Trivette on Walker,
Texas, Ranger. When asked by why Walker,
Texas Ranger is still popular to
this day, Gilyard replied to getTV,
"And here you are." "Here I
am, wearing a silver star."
From teaching film to playing pilots, priests,
cowboys, and computer-literate thieves,
Gilyard was a versatile, knowledgeable, and
compassionate individual. In his personal life,
Clarence Gilyard Jr. was a devout Roman Catholic.
He told the story of his conversion to the
Catholic News Agency in 2016. In 1995, Gilyard
hit rock bottom while living a hard-partying
lifestyle. Then, he crossed paths with a man
who invited him to Mass. It was a life-changing
experience for Gilyard. Gilyard's faith led
him to appear in the first two Left Behind
movies, Left Behind and Left Behind II:
Tribulation Force, as Pastor Bruce Barnes.
After Walker: Texas Ranger, Gilyard
took a break from acting in 2006 to
become an associate professor of film and
theater at the University of Las Vegas,
Nevada. Gilyard told the Las
Vegas Review-Journal in 2010,